les peines de prison que l'on donne ne
sont pas effectués c'est pour ça que
nous le syndicat alliance
on a demandé la création d'un
observatoire de la réponse pénale de
manière à ce que l'on puisse comparer
entre eux les peines encourues
les peines prononcées par les magistrats
et surtout les peines réellement
effectués et c'est sur l'effectivité de
la peine que pour nous il ya réellement
ce problème donc on peut nous aider nous
donner tous les chiffres qu'on veut que
la justice serait forte que la justice
serait impartiale et qu'elle passerait
par tous et cale sur et j'allais dire
vivant vigoureuse en attendant
l'effectivité de la peine
on le voit la réponse pénale est forte
mais de quelles réponses pénales par
bahloul parlons nous et c'est là où le
bât blesse
et c'est là où nous policiers nous avons
des tonnes et des tonnes d'exemples au
quotidien comme l'a dit monsieur alain
bauer
ce n'est pas sur le haut du spectre de
la délinquance que l'histoire se juge
elle se juge sur la délinquance du
quotidien le sujet surtout les faits qui
pourrissent la vie de nos collègues et
elle pourrit sur tous les faits qui
aujourd'hui dont sont victimes nos
collègues plus de 30 blessés au
quotidien par jour dans ce pays
ce chiffre ne cesse d'augmenter pourquoi
parce qu'aujourd'hui la violence et
désinhibée dans ce pays et plus personne
n'a peur de s'en prendre à un policier
surtout quand derrière il a comme
sanction un stage de citoyenneté ou une
admonestation de la part du magistrat
donc oui il ya un problème il faut le
dire il faut en parler et il faut que ça
cesse monsieur dupont moretti d'ailleurs
l'a reconnu dans différentes circulaire
parce que sinon il n'aurait pas pris la
peine d'écrire aux magistrats pour leur
demander de la fermeté contre ceux qui
agressent les policiers parce que dit-il
derrière ceux qui agressent les
policiers on s'en prend à l'état et à
l'autorité de l'état
donc en fait le constat est bien posée
sauf que la réalité pratique est tout
autre et c'est ça le problème
et c'est pour ça que le problème de la
police je le répète c'est réellement la
justice pas tous les magistrats pas par
une globalité de tout ça mais la manière
dont est rendu la justice dans ce pays
pose problème et et on en est victime au
quotidien
dans nos chairs et ça c'est inacceptable
[Musique]